- And good morning,
and we are really excited
for you to be here.
We're gonna deep dive into
the Database Savings Plan
that was just announced
yesterday during Matt's keynote.
Hopefully you had a chance to hear that.
It was the actual last item
before the buzzer beater, right?
So we are really excited
to dive deep with that
with you today.
It was one of the number one
requested features since,
for quite some time,
and the Compute Savings Plan
went live about six years ago.
We've added SageMaker,
but the demand for this
Database Savings Plan
has been extraordinary.
And that's because customers
see a lot of value in it
and also want flexibility.
My name is Adam Driver,
by way of introduction.
Not the actor Adam Driver,
but the Adam Driver that works at AWS.
I've been here for five years.
My role is a leader in our
solution architecture team,
primarily focused on databases.
So I've been living
and breathing databases
for quite some time
and have been doing it here at AWS
for the last five plus years.
And with me on stage today,
I've got Rick Ochs,
and I'll let him introduce himself.
- Hi, everyone, my name is Rick.
I lead the optimization product team.
So that includes products
like compute optimizer,
right sizing recommendations,
savings plan recommendations,
Cost Optimization Hub,
Savings Plan Analyzer, RI recommendations.
And I also sit on
the FinOps Technical Advisory Council,
representing AWS's perspective
and our customer's perspective
on the FinOps framework
and how it evolves over time.
- Great.
So we're gonna be your host
for the next 45, 50 minutes.
I love audience participation.
And we were talking to
some people earlier,
it'd be great to get a show of hands,
and I'm just a hand wavy person,
but to kind of understand who in the room
is with a FinOps group
by show of hands just to see...
Okay, there's a good quantity there.
And then how about DBAs?
Or people that are supporting databases,
maybe doing some Reserved Instances.
Okay.
And then a couple, no hands went up.
So I'm assuming you do both?
Or is there some combination there?
But let's just continue
the audience participation.
How many people, is this
your first re:Invent?
It's almost, oh, that's almost half
from what I can see.
Alright, so I don't want
everyone else to feel left out.
So if everybody who is
not their first re:Invent
can put their hand up, please,
and then put it down if it's your second.
Or your third.
You can start putting it down.
Fourth? Fifth?
We were going to see who's the longest.
Let's go to sixth, seventh, eighth.
I see two hands remaining. Ninth.
Oh, they both went down. Congratulations.
So if you have other questions,
we've got two people
that have been doing this
for nine years with us,
so thank you.
They can hopefully help
answer some questions.
But let's dive into the agenda.
We're here to talk about
how this is gonna work,
what it covers,
and more importantly,
some tools and technologies
and best practices
to actually make this work for you
and really maximize your savings.
So on the left, on the agenda,
is where we're gonna cover
Database Savings Plans.
A lot of excitement here
because the coverage will
really drive the engines,
the instance types,
as well as the the
provisions versus serverless.
So really cool capabilities
that the Database
Savings Plans will cover.
And most importantly,
the portability and flexibility.
If you leave here with nothing,
think about having flexibility
to turn new database engines on,
change the usage,
change how they're deployed,
and having that savings plan cover that
as you make choices in
architectural decisions.
We know that changes across regions,
the instance types,
as well as the deployment model
across dev test and
production are critical
for you to maximize that.
And then we wanna make sure we cover
the distant differences
between Reserved Instances.
A lot of the database
customers that I speak to
are buying specific Reserved Instances
for an engine type, for a workload
and really locking in
that three-year commitment
to maximize the savings.
We think there's some
additional flexibility
to go with that.
And Rick is actually gonna cover,
if you're heavy on Reserved Instances,
how do you migrate
or what is your plan to move
to a Database Savings Plan
if that's the path you choose.
And I think on the right side,
you will learn and hear,
you probably already know
a lot of these things,
but you'll see it in the technology.
We're gonna show you some live demos
that actually walk through
the recommendation part,
talk about the math behind the scenes,
and allow you to see some
scenarios that we've prepared
to kind walk through things
to maximize that utilization and coverage.
And last but not least,
we definitely wanna make sure you leave
with some best practices.
So why did we create the
Database Savings Plan?
Anybody?
- [Audience Member] Got
tired of us asking for it?
- (laughs) The nine-year person says
I'm tired of hearing us ask for it.
That's definitely customer feedback.
But we wanted to have that
portability and flexibility.
We wanted to make sure that
you had a pricing savings model
that would automatically drive savings.
Not that you would have to
recalculate it and figure it out,
but provide trustworthy recommendations
to allow you to drive
a one-year commitment.
So again, flexible,
automatic, and consistent,
that pricing model will drive savings.
It's different than the Reserved Instance
of a three-year commitment.
This is a one-year commitment
and there is no upfront payment.
And lastly, there's no waste
because everything that isn't covered
is billed at on-demand rates.
So you're really removing your waste
and maximizing your investment.
So let's talk coverage.
Everybody always wants to
know what does it cover,
what are the things it may not cover
in terms of corner case?
The Database Savings Plan
supports both Intel and Graviton instances
across Generation 7 and 8.
It covers both serverless,
kind of managed services
as well as your provision
deployment models.
And this broad coverage ensures,
regardless of your current architecture,
or as I touched on,
changes to the architecture
and future choices,
it can benefit these across
this Database Savings Plan.
So super excited about the coverage.
Here's a good shot to
maybe take a picture of.
This is the one that is
good to keep a record of.
This is details by database services.
There were a lot of data DBAs in the room.
I hope you're using the
right database engine
and maybe multiple database engines.
But on the left,
just to orient you on this slide,
the left covers the database services
that we currently support with
this Database Savings Plan.
There's two columns for discount.
One is if it's deployed
by specific instance type
and the other one is
if it's in a serverless
or more of a managed capability.
And then there's specific
details that talk about
which Generation of 7 or 8
and how it's covered
and what that maximum.
So just to walk through this.
Aurora, PostgreSQL at the top,
has a 20% discount for
instance deployments
and 35% for serverless.
So that is the highest
discount on the chart at 35%.
And then it calls out the details.
We wanna make sure that RDS SQL server,
we wanna make sure that the license,
bring your own license.
All of that is kind of covered
to the database instance usage.
Aurora DSQL, a little easier.
It's serverless only, and it's 18%.
And as we walk down, DynamoDB,
a very popular database,
is between 18 and 12,
and it's on-demand.
Throughput is 18%
whereas the actual
provision throughput is 12%.
So that's why you have two
numbers in some of those columns.
Again, I won't go through all of these,
but we're really excited
because the savings plan
covers all of those database services
that are listed on the slide.
Very, very powerful.
We think this will definitely
move the flexibility
and maximize savings for customers.
I'm gonna keep going.
So why is this flexibility and portability
that I've mentioned a few times important?
It's important because it
allows you to make a commitment
and then make changes and
choices along the way.
Your requirements are changing,
your demand and your capacity's changing,
and you don't have to
manage multiple commitments
or a particular workload
with a Reserved Instance.
You've got flexibility on how you do that.
So we really believe
the move usage between database services,
switch your engines,
as well as allowing you to bounce
between serverless and provisioned,
again, across your dev test
and production environments.
The change is really important
because we're constantly
becoming more resilient,
we're allowing you to move
across availability zones within regions,
stuff that you're doing today.
But the savings plans,
again, will allow you to have
that coverage and that flexibility.
The Reserved Instances
require specific reservations,
as you probably know,
the people that utilize those,
in particular instance types.
And this will allow you also
to allow you to be more dynamic.
And when it comes down in
having evolving architecture
that maximizes and meets
the business requirements you have today
and will allow you to adopt
to those in the future.
So again, flexibility, portability,
and this move switch, change, and adopt
allows you some really
good choices going forward
with the Database Savings Plan.
The next slide.
Again, the maximum saving? 35%.
Which service was that?
Yeah, from the last slide.
Thank you. Aurora.
So we're really excited about that.
It's a one-year commitment,
which is different than
the Reserved Instances,
which are three-year commitment.
And then there's no upfront payment.
There's some advanced pay options.
But again, the tagline I want
you to take away from this
is the savings and then
there's on-demand pricing
for anything else that is not covered
with the Database Savings Plan.
So really, really excited about that,
and, again, driving that flexibility.
How does it work compared
to Reserved Instances?
And I've talked about this a little bit,
and I don't know how many people
are really comfortable
with Reserved Instances,
but I wanted to just call
out just the big differences.
The first one is that the
Database Savings Plans
work with your existing,
your specific pricing programs
that you have in place.
They can be utilized with your discount
and your pricing agreements
for additional savings.
However, the Database Savings Plans
and the database Reserved Instances
cannot be combined on the same workload.
So there does have to be a
choice based on the workload
in terms of how you're actually
providing that discount.
Across dev test and
prod is a good example.
but let's talk a little bit more detail
on when should I use one or the other.
And then, again, the
common question we get
is if I'm using a lot
of Reserved Instances,
how do I migrate?
What is my strategy to get
to the Database Savings Plan
if that's where I want to end up?
So on the left here,
we think we've netted it out very clear
that you should use the savings plan
if you want to be able to move
between database services
and instance types
and we also want the ability
to adopt new technology really quickly
and try a new database service
without managing separate commitments
is a classic reason to use
the Database Savings Plan.
And then the goal is to
simplify your cost management
across all these database services.
However, there makes sense
to use Reserved Instances
for those of you that have
a stable, predictable,
known workload on specific instance types
that you've already implemented
and is not very spiky and just as,
and you know exactly what it is,
it makes sense to have a
three-year longer commitment
that maximizes even further discounts.
As I talked about,
you do need a reservation
for those Reserved Instances,
whereas the Database
Savings Plan, you don't.
At this point, I'm gonna
turn it over to Rick.
I think we've covered
just kind of what it is
and what the coverage is
and some of the flexibility,
and now I'll turn it over to Rick
to kind of dive a little deeper.
Thanks, Adam.
- Sure.
- So, as we were building
Database Savings Plans,
we talked to a lot of customers
about how they do their
purchasing strategies
and planning for compute savings plans
and instant savings plans as well
to learn about the pipeline and workflow
and the process of how do you
make the purchase decision,
how do you do your purchase analysis,
and then how do you track the
success of these purchases
after you've made that purchase.
So we have a little bit
of a lifecycle slide here
that shows the process.
First, determining what savings plan
you're going to purchase.
How much...
In this specific case,
there's less decisions you have to make
because it's already one-year, no upfront,
but how much you purchase
is still a really big part
of the puzzle to solve.
And once you add that to
cart and make the purchase,
then it becomes a bit of a tracking game
where you need to track
coverage, utilization,
and the discount you're
receiving from that savings plan
to make sure it's meeting the needs
and the expectations you had
when you made your purchase.
And then as you track your
coverage and utilization,
which we'll get into in
more details and depth
in a few slides,
you may find that you want
additional savings plans.
Say, there's more on-demand
spend to go cover,
there's more savings to go cover.
Tracking the coverage and utilization
will help you decide
when it's time to go back
to the beginning of this pipeline
and make some new purchase decisions
for your savings plan opportunities.
So we have a couple of
different options or methods
for purchasing new savings plans.
We have a recommendation product.
This is the same product that
if you're used to compute
savings plans today,
it's the same product, same experience,
same console location.
So hopefully for those of you
experienced and comfortable
with the savings plan product experience,
this won't be a new thing for you.
The idea is to make this
easy and comfortable
so there's not a lot of overhead
with managing and purchasing commitments.
So those recommendations are a
great starting point for you.
Those recommendations will look at
all of your historical on-demand usage
and find the most optimal
highest discount purchase amount for you
based on that historical usage.
And you can just click add to cart
and you're off to the
race in saving money.
For more advanced users,
you probably want to test out
different purchase amounts,
maybe look at different specific
periods of time in your history.
And we have a new product we
announced last year re:Invent
called Savings Plan Purchase Analyzer.
This has been a very popular
tool for our FinOps customers
that are doing a lot of analysis
and purchasing decisions
who maybe wanna layer different
savings plans together
or stagger their purchases.
This product helps
because it'll show you the
same kind of information,
how much you're gonna buy,
how much discount you're gonna get,
the coverage and the utilization
for any purchase amount you want.
And so that's maybe a
more advanced approach,
but what's interesting is you
can kind of easily transition
from the recommendations
to Purchase Analyzer
and maybe test out
different purchase amounts
quickly and easily
by moving between the
two product experiences.
So as we discussed,
the first question is how,
what are you going to purchase?
In this specific case,
Database Savings Plans.
But we really want to know
how much savings plan?
Is there any other details?
Is it specific?
Are you going to buy for
a specific linked account?
Are you going to buy a savings
plan for your payer account,
which will cover all of the usage
in all of your linked accounts?
And so that decision,
what are you purchasing,
whether that's maybe a Reserved
Instance or a savings plan.
Then it goes to how much to purchase,
which we have a recommendation
and Savings Plan Analyzer products for.
And then tracking usage.
In the Billing and Cost
Management console,
we have coverage and utilization
reports for savings plans.
So you can track over time, continuously,
how much savings you're getting
and what percentage of your usage
is covered by your commitments.
- Hey, Rick, a question that we get a lot
is how do we,
what's the math with that recommendation?
I know we produce a recommendation,
but what's the math behind that,
and we know it's trustworthy,
but how trustworthy is it?
- That's a great question.
So we get that question
from a lot of FinOps teams
that are trying to figure out, like,
should I build a spreadsheet
and look at my on-demand cost myself
and download the ker and look at it.
And the idea behind the recommendation
is we want to do that for you.
It's a lot of heavy lifting
and it's a lot of math.
And so in our recommendation algorithm,
we use something called a
golden-section search algorithm,
which is actually,
like, you can open up
Google and type it in
and you'll see golden-section search
is a very common algorithm,
but what it's doing is it's testing
a bunch of different purchase sizes
and finding the one with the
highest amount of savings.
And it doesn't necessarily mean
that it's finding the low usage amount,
because as your usage accrues over time,
you're gonna have peaks and dips,
especially with serverless,
because you may be having,
like, spiky workloads during the day,
and during nights and weekends,
you have no load.
Or maybe you're a company
that has a lot of usage
weekends and nights, as an example.
And so these spikes and dips in your usage
mean that a recommendation will find
how much of those spikes
and dips you should cover
for the maximum dollar amount of savings.
And so the recommendation in this graph
is sort of in the middle there.
And if you purchase more
than the recommendation,
you'll actually net a
little bit less savings.
And if you purchase less
than the recommendation,
you will also net a
little bit less savings.
So the recommendation is
designed to find, mathematically,
the highest dollar amount
of savings that's available
based on your historical usage.
And you can pick in the recommendation
7, 30, or 60 days look back period.
So if you have changes in
your environment recently,
you can kind of pick the window of time
that is more representative
of what you believe will
be your future usage.
- [Adam] And even with
custom dates, right,
it's not just fixed, it's-
- So, yeah, well,
so in Savings Plan Analyzer,
you can do custom dates, which is a,
it's a nifty trick,
and I'll demo that as well.
So as an example,
we made a little bit of an image
to show that, like,
we analytically graph out how much savings
or what the total cost is
and find the absolute lowest point of cost
for what specific purchases you can make.
And that's what
our savings plan
recommendation algorithm does.
And it's very important
that we're transparent
with how the recommendation is generated
by showing the utilization graph,
the cost graph,
so that way you can always
double check the math yourself.
But what's really cool is we actually take
a little bit of your monthly bill end code
that we run to publish the bill,
and we run the part of it
that calculates your savings plans
being applied against your resources.
So we actually run
a part of the end of
month bill computation
when we generate the recommendations
to double check that it's going
to yield exactly the savings
as long as your usage is similar
to what it was in the lookback period.
So what changed?
What's new in the console?
How many of you are familiar
with the recommendations
or Savings Plan Analyzer products
in the console today?
- Good number, yeah.
- Okay, awesome.
I like seeing that.
You'll see now,
as of yesterday at, like, 8:00 AM,
a new option in the recommendations
and purchase analyzer.
You'll see Database Savings Plans
is now an option for you to click
and get those recommendations.
The recommendations are already generated
and available on all of your accounts
where there is eligible on-demand usage.
So you can select that,
you'll immediately see
these recommendations
populate on the bottom,
and then you can click View Details
on these recommendations.
Now there's a lot of colors
and graphs on the slide,
so we're gonna go through it individually.
You'll see the first graph
on a new recommendation
is how much you're currently covering
with existing savings plans,
how much the recommendation
is advising you to purchase
to cover additional on-demand,
and what is the remaining on demand
that is not ideal to
cover with a commitment
because the discounter
savings is not positive.
So that is the left graph.
And you can just track over
time and understand, like,
okay, here's how much
I'm gonna have leftover
and here's how much
coverage I'm going to get.
Note that your FinOps teams will love you
if you make a lot of these purchases
because the bill month over month
gets much more stable and consistent
when you convert your on-demand spend
to a flat hourly rate savings plan.
So your finance people will love this,
the people that read the bill
and try to make sense
of it and explain it,
having a nice consistent
flat rate hourly fee
is much easier to handle
because you have less
variability in your spend.
On the right side of the screen
we have the coverage graph.
This will show you how much
of your on demand spend
is being covered by this
newly recommended commitment.
And it will also show you
what your current coverage is.
So if you already have some
savings plans for databases...
Maybe not, but...
Although I did have
some customers yesterday
already make savings plan purchases,
which is pretty cool.
- All right.
- You'll see your current coverage
and then what the coverage would be
if you purchased the newly
recommended savings plan.
So coverage is very important.
For those of you in the
audience that are FinOps,
you know a lot of companies target
a certain average coverage percentage.
They want to cover 70, 80,
90% of their on-demand spend.
They want to leave a little bit left over
for maybe if they're gonna
run an optimization campaign
like migrating to Graviton
or going to serverless.
Those are important elements
of how to make your decision.
And then on the bottom right
you'll see how much of this savings plan
will be consumed or used.
And there may be dips in this graph,
and it's important to note
that it's okay to have dips in utilization
and have a little bit of
savings plan go unused.
- [Adam] I'm always drawn
to this utilization chart
in the lower right
and what Rick just touched on.
For those of you that
might not be in FinOps,
why wouldn't I just do a blanket coverage,
ensure that I had a
hundred percent coverage
or 105% coverage, Rick,
versus that optimal amount?
- [Rick] You can either, like, optimize
for max coverage or utilization
and you kind of have to pick
which one's more important to you.
But if you maximize your utilization,
it means you're buying
a smaller savings plan
that's always gonna be fully used.
It means you have a lot more
leftover on-demand spend
that you're paying the
full on-demand price for
instead of having it under commitment.
So we do talk to customers
that they see an unused savings plan
and they're like, "We don't want that."
But you actually get more savings
if you purchase the recommended amount,
which doesn't always have a
hundred percent utilization.
- [Adam] Makes a lot of sense.
Okay, so we talked a little bit about
how the recommendations work.
Now we're gonna talk
about how savings plans
apply to your usage.
When you're using purchase
analyzer or recommendations
or even when your bill,
your month end bill process is running,
savings plans will apply
to the highest discount resources first.
This is really important,
because, as Adam mentioned,
serverless has a higher discount.
35% for RDS and Aurora.
That's an amazing discount.
We want to make sure you
get absolutely every dollar
of that higher discount first.
What that means is that 35%
Aurora serverless pricing
will always consume the savings plan first
and then it'll go down the
list in the discount amount.
Meaning, first we consume
35% Aurora serverless,
then ElastiCache, and then DynamoDB,
and it steps down by the discount percent.
So as you purchase more
and push your savings
plan coverage higher,
you get sort of like diminishing returns
as you get closer and closer
to your break even point
or your highest ROI.
So you will get the highest savings
with smaller savings plans,
but the recommendation
will calculate all of that
and tell you what the
ideal purchase amount is
for max savings.
So how do we see customers
using savings plans today?
This is important because
a lot of companies
have invested time and analysis and effort
into coming up with purchasing strategies
and plans for how to approach
fairly expensive and important investments
for the future of their cloud spend.
What we see is laddering
or incremental purchasing
becoming a very popular
method for FinOps teams.
And what this means is
you can purchase a savings plan right now
before you leave the conference
and start saving immediately.
And it doesn't have to be
the full recommended purchase amount,
it can be a smaller amount.
You'll immediately get some savings,
especially if you're running serverless,
with a pretty high discount amount,
the highest discount amount,
'cause it'll be applied first.
And you can always purchase more.
There's really not a downside
to staggering or layering
purchases together
because you can always revisit,
and if utilization changes or grows,
you can make another purchase.
There's not really a downside.
All of the savings
plans will work together
and apply to all of your usage together.
So purchasing incrementally,
whether that's monthly,
sometimes quarterly,
some customers, we actually see
weekly savings plan purchases.
And this is really cool
because for those of you that
have been patiently waiting
for an RI to expire
and kind of getting a
little antsy with that,
having incremental purchases means
you're not gonna have one giant
expiration of a commitment
12 months from now
that you have to wait for,
and you'll have kind of more staggered
expirations of your commitments
in case maybe your usage drops, right?
So this is a nice way to
get even more flexibility
out of your savings plan purchases
by laddering and staggering them together
to kind of build up to
the amount of coverage
you want for your spend.
So how do we move from Reserved
Instances to savings plans?
So we know a lot of customers
use Reserved Instances for RDS,
and those are one- or
three-year commitments
that you can make to receive a discount
for a specific instance type
in a specific region or zone.
And what we heard is a lot of customers
really like migrating to Graviton
or moving to the newest
instance family and generation
to get better CPU performance,
which also allows you to use
things like compute optimizer,
right size recommendations,
personal fan of that.
So making sure that you
have that flexibility
to make those changes like
Adam talked about that,
that if you're gonna migrate,
maybe change database services,
go to serverless,
that flexibility was key.
And so deciding your
overall commitment strategy
of where you're gonna be making
Reserved Instance purchases
for those stable workloads
that are not gonna change for a long time,
and then using savings plans
to essentially layer on
top for all of your usage
that may be more flexible
or change over time.
And so you can do both.
You can use your Reserved Instances
for your stable long-term workloads.
But for that usage that maybe
you need more flexibility
or you have plans to move to Graviton
or do optimization programs,
that savings plan flexibility
is really important for you.
So deciding on a commitment
strategy is important.
Establishing what does your
utilization look like over time,
what does your spend look like over time,
and how much of that do you want to cover.
So as you're going through this process,
the most important part
of Database Savings Plans
is that it's not one service,
it is nine services of usage.
This allows us to stack the usage
from all of these services together
and cover more of it because,
say, your DynamoDB usage is dipping
but maybe your RDS usage is increasing
certain hours of the week.
By stacking all of this usage together,
we can cover more of that usage
with a single savings plan
or multiple savings plans.
We believe will allow
you to purchase and cover
more of your usage with more discounts.
And especially for serverless,
which did not have a
discount offering previously,
this is a brand new discount.
So we believe this will save
a lot for our customers,
and we're really excited
to see it in action.
So combining usage
for all of your database services together
will allow you to make bigger purchases
and achieve more savings.
So you can also...
So you can look at the individual services
and usage for the services,
you can make Database
Savings Plan purchases
for those services,
or you can just combine
and look at all of that usage together,
which is what we do in the recommendations
and Savings Plan Analyzer tool.
So moving from Reserved
Instances to savings plans,
I think one of the interesting
migration strategies
would be to wait for them
to expire for each service
and then you take that on-demand usage
once it frees up
and comes off of a Reserved Instance.
And then you can start to
put together a purchase plan
and gather that utilization information.
And maybe if you would like to
repurchase Reserved Instances
for those stable workloads
and then convert the
rest to savings plans.
So purchasing for maybe
sort of like an 80% target,
get your coverage,
get your highest discount
usage done first,
and then you can leave that 20%
for maybe future plans on
modernization, right sizing.
Switching to Aurora I/O-Optimized,
another great option.
So one way to think about this
is to track the expiration
dates of your Reserved Instances
for each of your services.
So in the RI inventory console,
in the cost management console,
you can track the expiration dates
of all of your Reserved Instances
and then make a plan for aggregating
all of that usage together
for all of those services
and then start covering
them with savings plans.
So by tracking all of that,
we can convert all of the usage
from all of these different services
into one pool of usage and spend
for all of these nine database services,
and track and manage them
to make your purchases.
We talked a little bit about staggering.
So here's a little bit
of a visual example.
As your Reserved Instances expire
or as you maybe work
with a lot of your
different engineering teams
and understand what
resources they're running
and how they're running them,
you can incrementally add and increase
the amount of savings
plan coverage over time
by making those purchases.
Here's an example of over
time as your RIs expire.
You can either repurchase RIs,
you can convert to savings plan spend,
and by doing so you can
increase the amount of spend
that is covered by a discount
or a commitment over time,
yielding a higher total amount of savings.
We feel that with Reserved Instances,
a lot of customers were
hesitant to make that purchase
because you maybe didn't
have high confidence
in knowing the future of, like,
maybe a new instance type comes out,
we would like to optimize or migrate to,
or we're not sure if this workload
is gonna exist in six months.
And that flexibility of
Database Savings Plans
will provide some sort of insurance.
So you know you can utilize that discount
with any other resource type.
Once you've made your
purchases in the console,
you can go to the Billing
and Cost Management,
cost and utilization reports.
Here's an example of what it looks like
after you've made your purchases
and you would like to track
how much of that spend
is being covered by a new savings plan.
This is really important
because if your coverage starts to dip,
that's a great opportunity
to go and analyze
whether you would like to
make additional purchases,
or maybe some engineering teams
spun up some new resources
and they're utilizing those resources
for a brief period of time.
Maybe they're testing something out,
maybe they're kicking the
tires on a different service,
or scale testing or load testing.
and understanding why the coverage dip,
coverage has a dip is important
because it may not be a moment
where you wanna make a purchase for that.
It may be something
where an engineering team
is testing something or
trying something out.
Okay, we're gonna switch over to demo now.
- I'll let you do the demo.
- Okay, so here's the Billing
and Cost Management console.
For those of you in the FinOps space,
I'm sure you're very comfortable
and familiar with this.
For those of you with a more
of a database background,
a non-financial background,
this is the location that
all of our FinOps customers
spend a ton of time
to look at and understand
their costs, their spend,
usage data details, recommendations.
You'll also see we have a product in here
called Cost Optimization Hub.
That'll get you Aurora
I/O-Optimize recommendations,
RDS right size recommendations,
IDL recommendations
to help you optimize and save even more.
In the Billing and Cost
Management console,
on the left side,
you'll see recommendations
and purchase analyzer.
Again, these are the same products
that you're experiencing
today, or have today,
or the last several years
for compute savings plans
and instant savings plans purchases.
So there's not really
a new product experience
here, necessarily.
We're just improving these products
to include Database Savings Plans.
As you saw in the slides,
we now have a new Database
Savings Plan option
in the recommendations.
Can you all see that screen?
It's a little small.
Yeah? Okay.
Once you select Database Savings Plans,
we will show you a recommendation
that we've already generated for you.
In this case, I can save $315 a month
on a recommended purchase.
And you can pick,
do I want a recommendation
for the payer level,
a specific linked account,
and do I want it based
on 7, 30, or 60 days?
We also have options for
savings plan term and option.
Those only apply to compute
and instant savings plans.
For Database Savings Plans,
they are locked at one year, no upfront.
So in this case,
I've increased my usage
a lot in the last week
in preparation for re:Invent.
So I'm going to pick seven days
'cause I think that usage is more
what I expect to have in my
environment going forward.
So I picked seven days.
And then we're gonna look
at this recommendation
and see what it tells me to purchase.
In this case, I've got some spikes.
I've actually been running
some serverless in my environment
for the last week or so.
I wanted to show what it looks like
to have a highly dynamic environment.
If you look at the recommendations
in your payer account
or for an account with a lot of usage,
you'll see lots of spikes and dips,
especially if you're running serverless
or say you're doing RDS auto pausing.
Does anybody in the audience do that
where you pause your RDS
instances for cost savings
for up to seven days at a time?
Okay, that's great.
So you're gonna see dips
and peaks in your usage
and it's really important
that the analysis
and the recommendations account for that.
So here I've got some dips
and some peaks in my usage.
And in this case, over
the last seven days,
I can save about 2000 a month
or 9% of the cost
just on my last seven days of usage.
But you'll see these dips
actually go below the purchase amount.
So I want to understand
what's happening here.
And so I can click over
to the coverage graph.
This is the same graph
we showed a little bit
earlier in the slides,
but I want to know what percentage
of the spend or usage I have
is going to be covered by
this new recommendation.
And I can see that it kind of dips
between 76% and a hundred percent.
So that's sort of my peak to mean,
that's my high and my
low of usage over time,
and that's what a new
savings plan would cover
when it comes to my spent.
Then I want to track
how much of this savings
plan is being consumed.
Am I leaving any of that
savings plan on the table?
Now again, I would advise you
not to think of it as waste
because you still get a
higher amount of savings.
I'll give you an example.
Say you turn an instance
off on the weekends
for say 20% of the time,
but you have a 25% option to save.
It's still worthwhile to buy
a commitment or a discount vehicle
because that 5% extra savings
will yield you a lower total bill.
But it means your
commitment might not be used
a hundred percent of the time,
and that's perfectly okay
because the whole idea
with optimization here
is to ultimately lower the bill.
We wanna see that number
as low as possible
with no impact on performance
and availability of your
workloads for your customers.
So seeing utilization
below a hundred percent,
like we talked about earlier,
it's okay, don't run from it,
it's not the boogeyman.
Some FinOps teams,
they chase this down to zero,
they want zero unused commitments,
and we recommend targeting
your total savings amount
or your coverage amount instead.
So if I scroll down,
you can see some additional details.
These won't really change a whole lot
for Database Savings Plans,
but you can see if this recommendation
is at the payer level,
the lookback period,
the average hourly utilization by percent
if you want to target
a specific percentage.
And same with coverage.
You can see an average
coverage percent here.
Again, a lot of FinOps teams
will target a specific number here
because they want to cover
a certain percentage of their spend
to minimize risk and
maximize the flexibility.
Okay, so that's the recommendation.
So that's the out of the box experience
for what we've already
generated for you today
in your console.
But, you know, if I know
that I've got like some usage patterns
that are more representative,
I can click over here to purchase analyzer
and now I've got a lot more control
over the engine that populates
and calculates the recommendation.
And I can actually come in here
and I can change the lookback period
to any custom range I want.
And I was running a lot of server lists
and higher usage
between the 28th and the first.
I was running some usage over the weekend.
So I can pick this specific date range
and then I can run the
recommendation engine again.
So we're gonna run analysis.
And it's gonna take a few seconds
because it runs a portion
of your month end billing process code,
which applies and simulates
all of how the savings plans will apply.
And once that runs,
you're gonna get that same set of graphs.
In this case, it's telling me
there is a flat rate purchase to make
that will fully cover
everything of $29 an hour.
That's a pretty big savings plan
and it's gonna save me over $5,000 a month
and it's gonna, estimated,
save me 21% off of my spend.
So again, the more
serverless you're using,
you're gonna have higher discount amounts
and it's gonna be consumed first,
and so you'll see this number go up.
But I know that I had some
dips over this period of time
and so I wanna understand that.
So I can come into
utilization to understand
how much of that new savings
plan is gonna be consumed.
And this may be an opportunity
actually as well for optimization
where if I've got some periods
of time of low utilization,
I can schedule ETLs or backup jobs
or some of that sort of other
usage in those time periods
to consume that savings plan as well
to maximize your discounts even more.
Oka, so that's what it looks like
to customize your lookback period.
But what if, you know,
I'm not sure if that's the amount I want,
and, you know, $29 an
hour is a big commitment
and I have to go get
approval from finance,
and I don't wanna do that,
but I have auto approval for
anything under $15 an hour.
So I'm just gonna type in $15 an hour
and I can run that same exact analysis.
And it's going to calculate
all of the savings
plans per hour coverage,
utilization and savings amounts.
And here we go.
We can see the leftover on-demand usage
that's still gonna be out there.
And this is great if you have a strategy
of purchasing savings plans incrementally.
Again, we hope before you
leave for the conference,
you can engage your FinOps team
or go in the console
and think about making
a purchase right away.
It doesn't need to be the
full recommended amount,
but you can start saving with
the highest discount amounts
on your like serverless
and other high discount savings services
pretty quickly by just
making a smaller purchase.
Leaving a little bit of that on-demand
for additional future analysis
optimization programs or campaigns
just still leaves you that flexibility
to make some more optimization
and FinOps decisions later.
So you can make these
smaller purchases like this
and use purchase analyzer to make sure
you're still netting some good savings.
In this case, because we
purchased a lesser amount,
we're still getting most of the savings.
We're still getting $3,200 of the savings
even though the commitment we made
is quite a bit less.
So again, you still yield a
very high amount of savings
when you buy smaller savings plans
'cause it consumes the
highest discount first.
So once you do these analysis
and you have different
look back periods...
I'm actually gonna switch to a seven day.
And we're gonna look at,
say the last seven days
is more representative
of what I want to do.
And I want to see how much the system
recommends me purchase
based on the last seven days.
One you make these decisions,
you can quickly come in here,
refresh the recommendation,
get the latest data from
the most fresh usage,
and then you can click this
add up cart button right here
and make your purchase.
In this case, we're
recommending a $22 purchase
for $2,400 a month in savings,
and you can quickly just add to cart
and make your purchase.
Once the purchase is complete,
and you'd like to actually....
Sorry.
Another question, Adam, was,
what if I made a mistake?
What if I over purchased?
What if, like, I'm afraid
of making the purchase
because what if I find out
we were doing a migration
and I wasn't aware of it,
or something like that?
You have seven days to
return a savings plan
as long as it's within the same month.
So I recommend, generally,
if you're not a hundred percent
positive on your purchase
to not purchase at the end of the month,
'cause once the month rolls over,
we close the bill.
But you have a seven day window
to return any savings plan
under a hundred dollars an hour.
So this is a really nice feature.
It protects you from any mistakes,
fat fingers, or anything like that,
if you accidentally added
another zero in the purchase,
things like that.
So this seven-day return button
is something we launched
a couple years ago,
and this just helps
increase the confidence
that it's okay if you
fat finger something.
You're not gonna go
half to engage support,
you can just return that savings plan.
And even if you make the purchase
and begin to track
coverage and utilization
and it's not looking right,
your coverage is way too high
or your utilization is way too low,
you can return that savings plan
and purchase a different amount.
Okay, so moving on to coverage
and utilization report.
Say we've made the purchase,
then I can come in here
and look at coverage,
and this will show you
what percentage of your on-demand spend
is covered by the purchases you've made.
Now my coverage is really low
'cause I made a purchase
and then I returned it
because I wanted to have
nice big recommendations for the demo.
So my coverage is pretty low,
but you can come in here and track
how much of your spend is being covered
by commitments and discounts.
And then you can also look at
what resources are
consuming what commitments.
In this case, I've got
a bunch of compute spend
here and everything,
but you'll see these line items
for these different services
and which services are consuming
which amount of your savings plan spend.
So you can filter and click
through different service types
to understand which ones
are contributing the most
to the savings you're achieving
from your savings plans.
Alternatively, we have
the utilization report
which will show you what percentage
of your savings plans are being consumed,
like we showed earlier in the slides.
So that's it for our demo.
I'm gonna switch back to the PowerPoint,
invite Adam back up on stage here.
- Let's give Rick a round
of applause if we could.
(audience applauding)
He covered a lot of ground with that.
Really well done.
I think these technologies
that are in place in the billing console
are incredibly helpful.
And hopefully you saw something new,
at least the icon for
Database Savings Plan.
If you haven't seen that before,
or you haven't seen that before,
'cause it went live yesterday.
As we close this presentation...
And we'll be around
following the presentation.
If there's any questions,
feel free to come on up.
But our recommendation and call to action
is definitely to access it.
As Rick just covered,
no mistakes, right?
You can do that return within seven days.
But identify it, share it with your teams,
access it, try it,
see what the recommendations are doing.
Isolate that custom range
where you know you have
something interesting going on
in your environment
and see what the
recommendation comes back with.
So that's access it, try it,
we think is incredibly important.
And as always, we want your feedback,
we want your feedback from this session,
which you probably have on your phones
to fill out a quick survey,
but we also have some websites.
And I know Rick and myself
will make ourselves available
to answer any questions
that you might have.
But send feedback.
You know, we'd love to hear
how this is working for you
'cause it is a really
important launch for us
that some people in the room
have been waiting for nine years,
I think, by those hands.
So thank you for attending.
It was great doing this with you, Rick.
Appreciate it.
And enjoy the rest of your re:Invent.
- Thanks, everyone.
- Thank you.